and this is what if modernism is worth
anything then it should carry us to a
sense of the fragile nosov knowing you
know there are no platonic archetype
girdles showed that simple arithmetic is
fraught with uncertainty things that we
thought were so ripped in adamantine
that they could never be questioned like
the second law of thermodynamics turns
out to be written in sand to somebody's
opinion it applies locally in some cases
sometimes so the way to live with a mind
in the world with a human mind in the
world is not to believe things that's
childish it's it's it's undignified the
thing to do is to build models and to
call them that call it model building
and why because the implication is if
you exceed your model or if the thing
you're studying has dimensions your
model can't encompass throw the model
out you don't round up everybody who's
against the model and send them to the
wall because God revealed the model this
would be the usual method of a vacuum no
then you have provisional ever-changing
relationships to the world another way
of thinking about this is that what
ideology tries to do is create closure
there's something in the human mind we
want to finish the crossword puzzle we
want the good guys to win we want the
equinoxes to happen against the same
pattern of fixed stars in other words we
want order worse than that we want
narrative but this again is childish the
world is not a bedtime story it is not a
narrative it does not have
and black hats and so part of this
growing up thing or growing the on
culture or Deenie organizing one psyche
is to accept a lack of closure you know
that if it doesn't come to an end it
never makes sense
there is never the moment of resolution
we want it we want it we deserve it but
it ain't in the cards everything all
these transmutes itself and and opens up
new avenues of possibility so learning
to live without closure and I think this
is very hard for people you know I think
and a lot of decent impulses serve this
and tend to make people more neurotic
for example relationship anxiety people
want stable relationships
well they might as well wish for a
silent ocean you know all the wishing
for stable relationships brings you is
further anxiety about you're obviously
unstable relationship of people want
answers but you know say well I I
believe this is that I believe in
reincarnation so then that settles it
that means you don't believe in a whole
bunch of other things but yes yes it
makes the world so simple but you can
make the world so simple you can just
tile over every open question with a
dogmatic position and then when you've
entirely done this you're so awesome I'd
we can just toss you in a hole and bury
you and you will then have achieved this
closure that you were so frantic to
create in life that's the
that wonderful line from the movie HUD
where he says the only piece you ever
know is when they lower the box well you
might as well get used to that if that's
your idea of where you want to go whoa I
don't know it's on my idea of where I
wanted to go you know that place in
Andrew Marvell's poem to his coy
mistress where he says the graves a
lovely private place but none do there I
think embrace always at my back I hear
times winged chariot hurrying near so
get your bloomers off and get over here
a paraphrase admitted but that was
thought yeah living with lack of closure
and you know I've been trying to do this
and it's a acquired taste
it's not easy but it's sort of like
doing eating bran muffins once a day or
doing your calisthenics or something
gets it it's a healthy thing to do which
takes an athlete and to
you know I recommend it simply because I
think it makes it easier to-- to -
laughs to groove with what's going on I
mean things become much more comical
once you have totally rejected culture
and then you just see what a crazy game
it is and and watch ordinary people with
the fascination you normally reserved
for television sitcoms I mean they are
living television sitcoms they're acting
out Seinfeld for you better than
Seinfeld ever could the conversations in
the bath or a good place to begin
I mean how people deliver these lines
with a straight face I do not know but I
thank them for it how do I deliver my
lines with a straight face I don't know
either
[Music]
[Music]